the drive was from just crippling  insecurity and needing approval and then  i think from like a behavioral  conditioning standpoint i got immediate  feedback that was positive and then i  was conditioned to continue those  actions now i continue to do them  without the original catalyst that got  them going to begin with so i don't  think i suffer from the insecurities as  much as i used to i'd say i'm probably  30 better than i was at the beginning  and it might just be because i have this  massive big pile of money that i can use  as an emotional crutch to why i'm not a  piece of [ __ ] i have come to accept that  i love working and i don't need to judge  myself for that or take in other  people's judgment on how much i should  quote do  like this is my life and this is what i  like doing  and their  ideals that they've arbitrarily made up  as what they define as balance are  irrelevant to me